okay so when I hit Mo I'm already at
show I don't want to be at half a
after and that that was my initial
thrust is my initial thrust
okay the body's going to heal just like
you saw it he you see so I hit the body
starts to yeld I'm tracking it for more
penetration
okay so don't have your arm out here
sliding
here on
hit boom where
I'm let's go back a
step boom that's
where
boom no claw oop sorry I miss no claw
[Music]
boom okay two
things you you can't hit and then you're
going to use your arm to get
here you
move with your hand getting there and
then this hits
him so this is all free space my hand is
there see go in was my right hand it's
going to go here on free space hits join
that it hits
him
around and then when I hit
him make sure that when you go here
let's say I go here you're not pushing
him with your
bicep you have to wait for him to go
off boom that's when that follow it you
start making that more seamless
wound I'm not going
here pushing him the Body Hit here
boom
boom second thing is the up angle when
you first hit CU right now his
body his body weight is going to create
opposing forces to my thrust it's going
to make more Y at that CHP don't hit him
where it's just going to displace him
pull against the inertia that he's
standing on so this hand goes this way
you
see so it goes around doesn't go
straight in you don't want it to go
straight in but make that full
circle it's going up boom
okay try slow
like hey so I'm going to go up watch his
weight goes up goes past his heels you
see now if you keep going up he's going
off the
Joe just like he he'd be going off the
Joe here once you push laterally it goes
off the Joe because he's able to do that
so when I go like this I start to work
with his ret in energy so I
hit here and then take advantage of
those heels when they're when he steps
and I try to get back over them again
when I get back over them there's more
resistance on that's feeding my weapon
so it's
going up
boom you guys see that okay so don't go
up in that's I lost energy okay and
don't stay
up it goes
up
down up down okay all right okay so um
what you're trying to do is like yes I
have a lever but I want that lever
connected to my
mass the bulk of my mass so if I
hit this and I bounce
off or I hit it and I absorb it in the
elbow there's going to be less energy in
here you get it I'm say okay and if I
just use my
arm there's less energy because there's
less Mass right okay so all all I'm
doing isting with my body
step don't want to come here cuz that's
arms you
see I don't want
to do
that it stays with my
M can add claw
but it's after you initial impact
boom
no that's idea all right so if I go like
this then I got to use my arm my arm
strength to get that in
place that's a k to
this there's less power there so push
push all my Jo you can use your hands I
don't care where you use your hands and
your body
okay this would be like how much
resistance is the target to what I'm
doing okay so don't let me move you you
could get a base get your
strongest you
see I can't I can't do it well
inversely right if you were a big Target
you waited a lot that energy is not
going to go into you it's going to come
back into me okay got it
but you can hold it and instead of using
my little
bicep I put it here you see and I'm
moving my body you can resist okay
resist you can say that the upward
angle right is taking
advantage that eventually I'm going to
get you behind your heels you see that
but the resistance of the inertia of
your gravitational pole down is allowing
the tip of the Joe to penetrate deeper
into it okay so I'm just here and I'm
just using my glutes my legs my quad and
my momentum which we don't even have
here so get your good freaking don't let
me move you okay don't let me move you
don't let me move
you that means I would hit him
lighter this
means I'm going to hit you pretty
freaking hard get it cuz energy is all
going into you okay so I don't want to
hit you here cuz now I got to use my
bicep I don't touch you until you here B
just like I don't touch you
here the alignment of the body happened
already so when I touch
you see everything's lined
up and I like a a on a horse here's my
jws
and same thing here's my
jws is what we're doing okay try it
again your your hand is is uh doing we
do this move so
much you don't go like
this you you make the full
circle comes underneath
[Music]
you we did see her not too long
ago down here down
[Music]
here the
down here down here not up
here it will sink with the
chi leave your hand up
here
different s
drawing Diagon cross your
body letting the letting it drop you
made it young Let It Drop let it
complete it
cycle don't make it y don't make it
young descending and you're holding it
up Let It Drop
okay let's go back to
St okay all right we'll carry on so this
is where I hit it don't I'm not doing
this I don't want tension in here that's
where my arm was so right AR left arm
and that's where it
stays okay stays right there not hit
okay we're going
on so I'm going to
hit that
y then I can get to Y where my knee is
in alignment with my toes don't go past
it okay that finishes the qu though my
foot doesn't step
straight slightly
in and when I hit him my ankle is
straight that's where I make contact
with
him then the qua continues the
motion by bringing the
knee to the toe
line just don't go past
it
okay so I'm doing the last drill goes
around drop slow don't lift this
boom that's where I make
contact boom slightly in not straight
slightly
in he gets projected on that initial MK
I find the in space following it and
then I'm going to dig over the top of
it boom boom
I can't read here what's wrong it's not
under you right I can't hear you the
right hand's not under you sure I'll
change that what's
wrong straight toes straight what's
wrong your knee's not at the Yang line
it's not the Y Line it's not at the yin
line
okay watch you hit the in line boom push
through
boom
boom okay let's go back to it can't
handle these two things at the same time
all
right um especially in Cha's
organization you know they're trying to
hit them with their hand I know my hand
is touching
him but I'm trying to hit him with my
body
doesn't matter what it is I know my
hand's touching him but I'm trying to
hit him with my
body with my
body okay not trying to hit him not
doing that don't want my fish loose in
this kind of stuff okay when being
separated from my
mouth all right so if you follow the
right hand and you're trying to hit him
with your right hand you're going to
want to bring the right hip in you see
now you brought the qual back and now
you have that problem again
so again we're inversely looking at the
equal and opposite reaction he pushes on
me he's going to move me
okay and that would inversely be well I
can't put much force into the power
hence that's why can't stop in okay I
want to turn it this way I'm in this
angle this is where I am
okay over
here not over here look at my shoulders
look at my hips I mean this angle okay
so when he pushes on this
angle we're not going
anywhere okay got it
so don't hit him with your hand your
right hand cuz you're going to want to
turn your right hip like it's a reverse
punch it's not a reverse punch it's the
exact same
stance of
net so my foot is going to go in stay
there it's going to be slightly
turned I'm going to make contact with
the book of this mass at the in
ankle and then the qua finishes the
Thro body
pushing same
thing
underneath
hit
Yin bam he'll go okay turn the quaw this
way this this way not the other
way second
day you're at third Joe during this
whole
thing that's it don't slide anymore
don't have this
loose I'm holding the Joe with Ivy
adhesion so I'm not squeezing it but he
can't he can't push it back I'll move
out of the way push it we're
stuck you see you get it it so I'm not
here but I'm not loose where he pushes
it that's not that's that's weird okay
it's not
pull where I slide it through my front
hand do you get it it makes no freaking
sense because his mass is going to hit
it back and it slide is going to slide
back and I don't want it to slide back
so it does not this is yes it slides but
I'm not hitting anyone and yes it slides
but now it doesn't slide
anymore so it doesn't go here you see
that now I'm not a thir
joke or I
hit once I make contact that's it it's
in the adhesion everything is
going and I stay at third Joe if I undid
it I'd be at third
Joe now it's something
weird okay and let's do this one lastly
which won't happen if you do what I say
you can't you're going to keep your grip
and this is about all you can do the
only time you can nio
yourself is when you weren't holding the
weapon or you brought the other hip in
you're in this weird thing okay so you
don't have to kill me wait this smack it
out of my hand you see because that's
the same thing we use on Niko on him see
I can get out of his gri now cuz it it
loosens it opens the fingers whenever
you take the medic caral up the
arm so here you are you're doing that
you're going to knill yourself and the
mass is going to come back you see it
comes at weird angles his the reaction
here you're all like this it pops out of
your hand you don't want that you he
this is where you hit him and you hold
that and that's it this this no
no stay in in natural movement boom
done
boom okay try it again I going to make
this point again how's your joke
ski ends at third Joe third Joe is
shoulder
width okay you size your Joe so you can
do this three
times this is
shoulder okay that's where ski ends
so this is where he hits
me okay that's where he hits takes me
over my heels using my inertia my
scaning inertia as cling Force to
generate more y here allowing the small
surface area to penetrate my body okay
that's what's going to happen all right
if he goes to
hajo then whatever weapon I have I can
hit his arm that arm is in the middle of
the fight don't put things in the middle
of the fight that's on third show
okay let's finish the move
okay and if you look if he stays at
third Joe there's no freaking s in his
arm so we're going to make a s in his
arm you see you See the
s now if we undo it just hold it and we
go
back he's not a third
joke you see C move this one all the way
no this Sergio is supposed to be out
here go back where you
were and go to the first move you see
how much control you have of that tip
not a lot why it's far away yeah you're
at the other distal end you see that so
I have a lot of Leverage here you get it
and so does the mass of the target has a
lot of Leverage on you okay if you could
come out here you'd have a lot of
Leverage on that tip do you see but
what's the
downside you're in range for my weapons
my knives my swords my joke do you see
that don't go to half cuz you're in the
middle of the fight so you go to third
joke do you get it okay let's finish
this and get that crazy
Niko right and
again people uh hit weapons you see that
did that work yes it
worked okay this isn't a in a form I got
to take my turn that I'm going to be
really simple right or people strip
weapons you see because you're already
out and then I can disarm and in okay do
you understand right so I lose
leverage and I'm easily stripped of the
we been through just stupid ass I just
think I'm bigger than you oh do you see
and it's going to work it's going to
work and I'm in and okay or I'm a little
more technical right and I strip the
weapon the weapon got stripped okay so
you want to keep a grip you see the
difference lot different it's a lot
different okay but you do the
grip Escape mechanics onto yourself then
it's easy do you see cuz that's the same
mechanics we use to escape grips okay so
pay attention it's the reason
you over rotate the Joe is because you
think you're hitting with your hands so
you need to play pool do you know when
you play pool you slide the back end
through that's not what I'm doing okay
I'm holding this thing and look more
like I'm Shoveling boom right you
wouldn't shovel Slide the shovel through
right you hold it and you go in and you
move it you don't slide the shovel
through you get the dirt could you
imagine find me something your sister
would do right where we out there
working and she'd shovel like this no
boom your body your body okay got it
don't slide it through your hand and
cause those problems